et bien bonjour tout le monde j'espère
que cette vidéo va vous plaire
passez-vous une bonne journée
actuellement nouvelle vidéo de voile et
thématique aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de quelque chose que j'adore et
que mon papa m'a transmis et oui ça
vient de lui
je ne veux pas m'approprier ceux qui ne
m'appartient pas les documentaires
reportages animaliers à quelle belle
histoire d'amour je suis pas le seul à
aimer ça moi j'ai pas mal de gens qui
aiment la nature et qui du coup on aime
bien se renseigner sur la nature et qui
du coup regard des reportages sur les
animaux et c'est vraiment intéressant
alors des fois c'est très triste la
nature est très brutaux le naturisme
wild 2 comme on dit mais d'autres fois
il ya juste des situations qui sont un
peu rigolo alors aujourd'hui j'ai fait
une petite sélection des vidéos du net
du monde animal qui me font vraiment
marrer j'aimerais vous les présenter
après si vous n'êtes pas sensibles mon
animal aux animaux et ses terrasses
espagne 2 vous avez forcément aimer mais
en vrai on a tous une petite sensibilité
ne mentait pas vous n'êtes pas
insensible armes animal qui possèdent
des poêles ou une peau et cahiers où sa
dépense et les goûts et les couleurs
mais voilà ça vous touche forcément
quelque part allez on y va première
vidéo je vous fais un petit topo parce
que c'est là elle peut être
impressionnante quand même
au premier abord c'est un [ __ ] de
serpents qui est monté sur un [ __ ] de
câbles électriques pour manger un [ __ ]
d'oiseaux non faire des livres ou le
serpent il fait tout ça pour manger mec
[Musique]
ça a un côté rigolo quand même nom mais
qu'on se le dise
regardez le il a repéré sa proie ça
prend à la repérer aussi elle se dit
mais c'est inhabituel de voir ça qu'est
ce qui lui prend assez fort depuis des
décennies nous sommes à l'abri moi et
mes congénères sur ce câble mais
aujourd'hui ils ont compris ils se sont
adaptés
franchement je veux pas te dégoûter
monsieur le serpent mais tu n'as
vraiment 0% chances d'y arriver zéro car
la cible que tu as choisi possède des
ailes et peut vraiment te faire en très
peu de temps
oh mon dieu
or mais cette scène au ralenti et c'est
jacques loiseau qui est vu immédiatement
becqueter une petites écailles du
serpent pour lui montrer qui est le
patron quel propriétaire de ce câble
électrique
waouh la provocation gratuite mais qu'il
a fait c'est incroyable non n'invitait
pas dans son élément là en vrai c'est un
peu tout ça veut dire que serpent il a
il a pas de nourriture au sol il ya plus
de nourriture ya plus de proies pour lui
au sol probablement à cause de l'humain
donc il est obligé de grimper sur un
câble pour retrouver sa bouffe c'est un
peu triste
et bientôt on retrouvera jacques loiseau
dans un terrier pour lapins la nature et
dérégler totalement voilà c'était une
petite maison dans l'aisne là c'est soft
c'est un peu bizarre mais c'est
tranquille on passe maintenant une carte
peut plus tourner souvent il ya des
vidéos comme ça d' animaux qui font des
dizaines voire même des centaines de
millions de vues pour certaines la plus
connue étant celle de l'iguane qui se
fait chasser par des serpents et qui
s'en sort miraculeusement avec une
dégaine incroyable je mettrais lire mes
sculptures n'a pas la garde et pascal et
elle est beaucoup trop connus mais y en
a eu deux là qui est aussi pas mal connu
qui est très amusante
en plus c'est des mammifères donc je
pars on s'identifie plus à des
mammifères je trouve c'est encore plus
touchant il s'agit d'un bébé lion d'un
lionceau qui fait de la merde il faut
arrêter les voix off sur les vidéos
comprenant des animaux il faut faire un
référendum
emmanuel macron s'il vous plaît chargé
vous ans on ne veut plus de gens qui
font la voit les animaux sur les vidéos
sauf celle là mais les voix humaines la
non arrêtez arrêtez c'est vidéo gag
c'est 2002 on arrête ici on a un groupe
de lyon et ici on a un groupe d'oiseaux
et le groupe de lyon veut bouffer le
groupe d'oiseaux bien entendu ici en
contrebas sur ce qui s'apparente est de
l'herbe mais en fait c'est pas de
l'herbe et ce à tous les lions ils l'ont
compris sauf un et va très vite qu frob
il s'approche donc ils sautent et il se
retrouve à nager le conte et qu'est ce
qu'il y avait dans cette eau
habib popote l'une des espèces animales
les plus énervés de la nature opus email
le tout fut mecque des herbes là sur le
crads incroyable et le lion bien entendu
avec l'agilité d'un félin va finalement
réussir à remonter sous le regard des
autres lions qui l'aident totalement
regardez ils sont en train de l'aider
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
et vous voyez en sortant de cette
épreuve ce lion deviendra un dangereux
prédateur de la nature comme celui-ci
troisième vidéo et je vous jure je suis
vraiment content de vous montrer ça
c'est des délires monga des fois je
passe deux heures à garder ça comme ça
et je regardais un mois si personne n'a
vu puisque j'ai et j'assume et j'assume
pas trop c'est très bizarre troisième
vidéo encore de la bbc bat façon josé
c'est le number one en contenu trop cool
chose animaux ils sont intestat ball ala
au regard des petites bêtises des
extraits des mini extraits de reportages
qui eux durent une heure et demie quoi
mais y'a vraiment des dd série
passionnante et je vous mettrais
quelques rêves dans des solutions pour
ceux que ça intéresse voilà continuons
notre épopée animalière à ça fait ça je
savais exactement ça je sais mais vous
allez voir ça va vous réconcilie un peu
avec les araignées je vous en fais la
promesse regardez donc cette araignée a
trouvé un bigorneau pas squeeze un autre
binôme et et c'est trop mignon mec parce
qu'elle va utiliser ce petit bigorneaux
qu'elle a trouvée pour se construire un
abri et je trouve ça fou qu'une araignée
s'adapte comme ça à ce qui l'entourent
genre elle a besoin d'être un petit
cocon shoah millions pour passer la nuit
et elle utilise un truc qu'elle a
trouvée pour le construire c'est fou où
elle va hisser le coquillage à côté
d'une branche r&d elle tisse sa petite
toile comme il faut je n'aime pas les
années mais là je trouve ça mignon bon
là elle panique un peu
elle gère pas de ouf ça c'est toi en tpe
totalement c'est une architecte regarde
bien le thème labs est magnifique et hop
elle dort dedans est ce que maintenant
vous allez vous méfier de tous les
migrants de vous croiserez oui en vrai
chaque truc où il ya un trou ou un
animal peut y voir un abri veut dire
qu'il ya peut-être un animal à
l'intérieur et ça je ne savais pas
vraiment vu cette vidéo la morale c'est
méfiez-vous des bigorneaux
alors ça moi ou il faut savoir que dans
la nature des espèces animales qui ont
des capacités qui sont vraiment
extraordinaire il ya par exemple lac ce
lot vous connaissez je parle pas de
youtube heures patrick boube c'est
génial je parle de l'animal qui est
presque aussi génial donc lui s'adapte à
son milieu naturel si on le met dans
l'eau ou sur mais dans un terrarium
il évolue différemment et surtout il a
des capacités régénératrices pas comment
s'appelle mais en gros quand tu me coupe
une batte
elle repousse quoi ce qui est assez
incroyable hélas il n'est pas question
de se régénérer mais il est question de
s'adapter face à aux situations mais
s'adapter en mode violent regardez
j'étais sur le cul quand j'ai découvert
ça lasse et national geographic nous
propose cette vidéo c'est bien citer les
sources et comme ça je mettrai toutes
ces chaînes description encore une fois
ci voulait faire des petits tours it et
vous documenter sur la nature c'est
passionnant à bernard l'hermite c'est
trop mignon
[Musique]
c'est bon pour vous ce n'est pas un
bernard l'hermite ces [ __ ] de pieuvre
mec c'est une [ __ ] de pieuvre mec qui
a appris à imiter le bernard l'hermite
on faire face à des situations bien
précises c'est pas incroyable
moi je sais pas me transformer en plante
quand je veux pas être vu un endroit je
sais pas en plus ses limites vraiment
bien elle bouge ses tentacules à l'avant
comme un bernard ami de feu réel mais
deux tentacules pour imiter ses yeux
qu'elle bouge pas y est c'est vraiment
troublant moi je tombe dans le panneau
direct elle le fait pour se défendre de
ces prédateurs du coup ces prédateurs
crois qu'il ya un crustacé et ils en
veulent pas ils veulent bouffer des
pierres ou des poissons ou alors à
l'envers ce qu elle veut bouffer elle
des petits poissons les poissons il se
méfie pas des bernardins mitch qui les
mènera vers ermite ne mange pas des
poissons et du coup elles vont en
profiter pour claque [ __ ] le poisson
dès qu'il s'approche un peu trop sacré
céphalopode n'est ce pas alors vidéo
suivante
ok maintenant je vais vous parler d'une
chaîne youtube qui est l'une de mes
chaînes préférées de youtube et qui est
assez vieille maintenant qui s'appelle
le zapping sauvage c'est francetv qui
propose ça et c'est du très très bon
contenu merci france l'avait d'ailleurs
de finance à ce que je trouve que sur
youtube il manque un truc la part des
youtuber c'est ce genre d'image ce genre
de trucs ils ont beaucoup beaucoup
d'idées sur cette chaîne l'a d'ailleurs
ils ont un million d'abonnés et il y en
a vraiment certaine qu'ils m'ont fait
chialer de rire et l'une d'entre elles
est la suivante c'est un reportage sur
des crabes géants sur une île est en
fait c'est dekra petits vols les
habitants et regardez c'est incroyable
c'est sur l'île christmas sur l'une des
îles les plus reculés d'australie en
australie bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
tout ce qui est animaux improbable
certes australie on sait bien quand je
suis arrivé sur l'île j'entendais frappé
gratter en plein milieu de la nuit
on croyait que la maison était hantée
j'ai posé mon sac par terre comme je
l'aurais fait n'importe où ailleurs
je vais aller faire un tour et quand je
suis revenu mon sac avait disparu il
avait ouvert il avait abandonné mon
appareil photo et volé ma bouteille
d'eau
regardez-la real n'a aucun intérêt n'est
pas incroyable sont des codes et les
plans sont les vieux crochets larges
arrive c'est à moi ça ne laisse pas
traîner tes affaires l'auteur de ces
vols à répétition
est le crabe des cocotiers waouh quel
colosse il soulève clairement plus de
fonds que nous armés de pinces capable
d'ouvrir une noix de coco en de wau il
un décapsuleur à son compte en plus pour
ne pas mourir de faim ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de chaparder bon le
fond de l'histoire un peu triste c'est
qu'ils y crèvent la dalle
il crée finalement la dalle et du coup
ils ont compris que dans les maisons des
humains il y avait à bouffer et ils sont
malins et s'introduisent vous voyez la
bouffe 20 mai mec tu rentres chez toi il
ya ce à quoi faut être sacrément serein
comme il ne se contente pas à des
aliments comestibles et regardez le lui
il fait ses courses à un crabe l'expert
comptable mais avec ça n'a aucun sens
ils dérobent absolument tout
des chaussures laissées devant la porte
aux couverts oublié sur la table un
crabe aurait même volée une arme
militaire
waouh je pense qu'il est évident qu'on
sous estime les arthropodes clairement
attend dé lui il est un [ __ ] de
couteau mais qu'il imagine tu marches
son flair sont fait exprès le crabe il
te plantes quoi directement il n'y a pas
de question personne n'osera mary et max
hurd est fasciné par ces animaux et
observent depuis longtemps leur étrange
comportement aubry l'ait pas fasciné au
vrai c'est leur otage les crabes ils ont
mis le couteau sous la gorge comme ça
ils ont du bon tu nous mets roger chaque
matin devant la porte
sinon tu plantes mon pote pour montrer
de quoi ces crabes sont capables ils
décident de leur tendre un piège avec
quelques objets banals et des caméras à
capteur de mouvement il revient le
lendemain pour relever les preuves
très bien ils sont venus les crabes se
sont montrés à la hauteur de leur
réputation
c'est incroyable une fois la nuit tombée
l'un d'eux s'est même enfui avec une
caméra espion ils sont incroyables ces
crabes j'en veux un
on va le voir partir avec natsu comme ça
sur son dos oh merde
l'explication est assez cool c'est juste
que quand le crabe bien et qu'il a un
doute sur la comestibilité d'un objet il
le prend et il le ramène dans un coin où
il peut être tranquille le temps de
l'examiner alors qu'ici le prend pas
avec lui même à se faire emmerder par
d'autres crabes qui vaut aussi dû voler
son butin du coup ça le fait chier il a
compris qui doit s'isoler quoi je trouve
ça vous en fait je suis touché par la
capacité d'adaptation de ces animaux
quad animaux on dirait qu'ils sont pas
forcément très malin parce que nous on
se croit clairement supérieure mais en
fait ils sont tellement malin on sous
estime tellement d'espèce c'est ouf
ok autre vidéo de zapping sauvage à lui
vous abonner ou à vous abonner à cette
chaîne à les y aller si l'âge mais une
fiche maintenant vous le fait maintenant
vraiment il s'agit d'une mante
religieuse qui est sur le point de se
faire bouffer par une araignée
c'est dans la nature c'est comme ça il
ya beaucoup d'espèces qui mangent
d'autres espèces pour survivre
simplement
ah bon cette espèce là les vrais marrant
parce qu'elle tente un bluff mon gars
c'est très courageux de sa part
clémente ont une vue sur développer mais
pas autant que les araignées sauteuses
regarder on dirait pas lucas the spiders
l'araignée là pour les enfants qui a
pour but justement de qui s'est pas peur
des araignées plus tard puisque c'est
très bien les araignées pour ne confère
pas toutes les espèces mais 90% des
araignées qu'on bute en fait elles sont
hyper utile pour nous je ne mens tu ne
sais pas encore volé tu vas y aller mais
ses longues pattes de devant destiné à
attraper t3 l'est dans sa fuite vient
jouer vas-y ma grande en fuite oav asie
oh là là c'est déjà rennais qui sautent
hors jeu la voix me sauter dessus j'ai
peur
mais elle a un secret
kung fu panda le kung fu façon mante
religieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est du bluff c'est du bluff lamente
tente simplement de paraître plus grosse
et de dérouter son ennemi
[Musique]
et ça marche tu ta faveur quel courage
bravo le bluff l'incroyable faut
l'inscrire au poker quoi cette mode la
[ __ ] survivre quelques heures est déjà
un exploit pour un insecte qui fit
naître est la base bravo si la chance
continue à lui sourire
mais oui dans deux mois la jeune mentor
qui dès sera grande et belle comme celle
qui se tient devant el ouahch césar
aller très très vite
[Musique]
mais on ne peut pas gagner à tous les
coups
les mondes sont cannibales
eh bien les abysses la fin de cette
vidéo sur ces petites séquences
animaniacs qui me qui me font vraiment
kiffé n'essaie pas aimé la vidéo ça vous
a plu et si vous êtes fan de ce délire
là bas tchèque et la description encore
une fois ou al'inverse donnez moi des
trucs à garder que peut-être je n'ai pas
vu tu très content d'avoir parlé de la
nature et des animaux dans cette vidéo
décidément on n'arrête pas ce moment je
vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien un [ __ ] j'ai
envie de regarder des reportages animé
toute la journée la zone trop envie ces
conneries
[Musique]